نقلت وكاله رويترز عن تقارير لوسائل
الاعلام الرسميه في كوريا الشماليه ان
زعيم البلاد كيم جونغ اون كشف عن اهداف
جديده للجيش لعام 2023 في اجتماع حزب
العمال الحاكم المنعقد في الوقت الراهن
واضافت التقارير ان كيميانج اون حدد اهداف
اساسيه جديده لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
الذاتيه استعدادا
لايقلبات في الوضع السياسي دون الكشف عن
اي تفاصيل واطلقت كوريا الشماليه عددا غير
مسبوق من الصواريخ هذا العام وتم تصميم
العديد من عمليات الاطلاق لتطوير اسلحه
الاستراتيجيه بموجب خطه امدها خمس سنوات
تم وضعها في مؤتمر حزب العمال في اوائل
عام 2021 تشمل القائمه اسلحه النوويه
تكتيكيه وصاروخا باليستيا جديدا عابرا
للقارات ورؤوس الحربيه
وقمرا صناعيه